Iniciando en casa, Argelia viajó cuesta arriba a la tienda de regalos por 45 minutos a 8 millas por hora.
Luego ella regresó por el mismo camino hacia
abajo a una velocidad de 24 millas por hora.
¿Cuál es la velocidad promedio de todo el
viaje, yendo de la casa a la tienda y de regreso?
Ok, lo que tenemos que hacer es calcular la
velocidad promedio...
velocidad...
promedio.
Y para calcular la velocidad promedio,
lo que tenemos que hacer es tomar la distancia total...
la distancia total...
distancia total...
total y dividirla entre el tiempo total,
entonces déjame dividir aquí entre el tiempo total...
tiempo total...
total...
Muy bien, ¿cómo le hacemos para encontrar
la distancia total y el tiempo total?
Déjame empezar con la distancia total.
La distancia total simplemente es la distancia
de ida y la de regreso, pero eso es lo mismo
que dos veces la distancia de ida hacia la tienda,
porque nos dice que...
que Argelia regresa por el mismo camino,
entonces la distancia total sería 2 veces...
2 veces la distancia a la tienda,
le voy a poner así, 2 veces la distancia a la tienda...
a la tienda...
y eso lo tenemos que dividir entre el tiempo total
y el tiempo total es el tiempo de ida,
le voy a poner aquí el tiempo de ida...
de ida...
más el tiempo de regreso...
el tiempo de regreso...
regreso...
Muy bien, observa que abajo puse el tiempo
de ida más el tiempo de regreso
y arriba puse dos veces la distancia a la tienda,
arriba es dos veces la distancia a la tienda porque
la distancia de ida es la misma que la distancia
de regreso, pero abajo no sucede eso,
porque el tiempo de ida y el tiempo
de regreso son diferentes, va.
¿Y cómo sabemos eso?
Pues porque arriba tenemos que la velocidad
es 8 millas por hora y abajo es 24 millas por hora,
entonces como Argelia camina más lento hacia arriba, entonces el tiempo de ida va a ser más grande
que el tiempo de regreso, va.
Bueno, vamos a ver de donde sacamos cada una...
cada una de estas cantidades,
lo primero que nos interesa es la distancia a la tienda,
pero la distancia a la tienda no nos la dan aquí,
afortunadamente lo que si nos dan es
cuanto tardó Argelia en llegar a la tienda
que son 45 minutos...
deja los marco en color verde...
y nos dice a que velocidad,
a 8 millas por hora, lo voy a marcar en color azul.
Entonces con eso podemos trabajar aquí aparte
para determinar la distancia a la tienda...
déjame ponerle por aquí, distancia...
un poquito más arriba...
le voy a poner aquí distancia...
distancia a la tienda...
a la tienda...
vale, tienda...
va, entonces la distancia a la tienda,
¿cómo la podemos calcular?
Pues multiplicando el tiempo que tarda por
la velocidad, entonces tenemos que son 45 minutos,
pero observa que esto está en minutos
y esto está en horas,
voy a pasar todo a horas, para que no,
para que no haya problemas con las unidades, vale.
Aquí tenemos 45 minutos, pasando esos minutos
a horas, tenemos que son 45 entre 60 horas...
45 entre 60 se simplifica a 3/4 de hora,
entonces lo voy a poner por aquí,
que estos 45 minutos son 3/4 de hora...
de hora...
Muy bien, entonces la distancia a la tienda
es 3/4 de hora...
3/4 de hora...
de hora...
multiplicado por la velocidad, que es 8...
8 millas... millas por hora... por hora...
hora...
Muy bien,
eso de ahí, ¿cuánto es?
Pues a ver, esto de aquí es igual a hora
se cancela con hora, entonces hasta el final
nos van a quedar millas, 3 por 8 es 24,
24 entre 4...
déjame apuntar eso, nos quedaría 24...
24 entre 4 y en unidades,
hora se cancela con hora y nos queda millas.
Entonces aquí sería 24 entre 4 millas y
eso de ahí es igual a 24 entre 4 es 6,
entonces nos queda 6 millas...
millas... vale.
Entonces este numerador es dos veces 6 millas
y por lo tanto esto...
esto lo podemos cambiar por 12 millas...
12 millas... sale, 2 por 6 es 12.
Ahora vamos a ver que sucede con el denominador,
tenemos que poner el tiempo de ida
y el tiempo de regreso,
el tiempo de ida ya nos lo dan,
son 45 minutos, pero otra vez estamos cambiando
todo a horas porque estoy suponiendo que nos
piden la velocidad promedio en millas por hora.
Entonces este tiempo de ida simplemente es...
deja tomo este color verde...
simplemente es 3/4 de hora...
3/4 de hora, sale...
Ahora lo que necesitamos es el tiempo de regreso.
El tiempo de regreso no nos lo dan,
pero nos dice que camina por el mismo camino,
entonces recorre la misma distancia y además nos dan
esta velocidad de 24... 24 millas por hora,
entonces ahora necesitamos un tiempo,
voy a ponerle aquí tiempo...
tiempo de regreso...
de regreso...
regreso...
Y ese tiempo de regreso es igual a la distancia
que recorre, es decir, a 6 millas..
6 millas...
porque de regreso se toma el mismo camino,
dividido entre...
entre la velocidad que tenemos.
Y la velocidad que nos dan es 24 millas por hora,
ahora va para abajo, entonces es
un poco más fácil caminar más rápido verdad,
entonces hay que dividir entre 24...
24 millas...
millas por...
un poquito más bonito...
por hora...
por hora.
Muy bien, y eso de ahí,
¿a cuánto es igual?
Pues vamos a ver, en unidades las millas...
las millas se cancelan con millas,
aquí tenemos 1 entre 1 entre hora,
así que nos queda horas... horas...
y en números nos queda 6 entre 24,
ambos son divisibles entre 6, 6 entre 6 es 1,
24 entre 6 es 4
y por lo tanto nos queda 1/4 de hora...
1/4 horas, vale.
Entonces este tiempo de regreso es de 1/4...
1/4 de hora.
Muy bien y con eso ya podemos calcular lo
que nos piden, la velocidad promedio es igual a...
vamos a ponerlo un poco más limpio,
es igual a 12 millas...
millas...
dividido entre 3/4 de hora más 1/4 de hora...
dividido entre 1 hora...
1 hora, sale.
Y esto es exactamente lo mismo que
12 entre 1 millas por hora...
ya lo voy a poner en color azul...
es lo mismo que 12, porque 12 entre 1 es 12,
12 millas...
millas por hora...
por hora.
Muy bien,
ésta de aquí es la velocidad promedio.
Ahora, te puedes preguntar,
¿por qué no simplemente promediamos
la velocidad de ida y la velocidad de regreso?
¿por qué no hacemos 24 más 8 entre 2,
o sea, 32 entre 2 = 16?
Bueno como te das cuenta eso da algo distinto
e incorrecto y la razón por la cual es incorrecto
es que aquí estamos recorriendo 8 millas
por hora durante más tiempo,
entonces esto debe importar un poco
más para el promedio, vale.
Entonces la forma de hacer esto,
la forma de determinar la velocidad promedio
es calcular la distancia total
entre el tiempo total.
Aquí simplemente la distancia total fue dos
veces la de ida, la de ida era 6 millas,
la calculamos con esta información y tenemos
que dividir entre el tiempo de ida
más el tiempo de regreso, el tiempo de ida nos lo
daban y el tiempo de regreso lo calculamos
con la nueva velocidad, la de regreso y la
distancia que ya habíamos calculado.
Bueno, espero que te haya gustado este video,
nos vemos en próximos videos.